hey guys how's it going welcome to ask
ij today's episode there's actually
people here at my house and they're
filming me filming you guitars filming
the people filming me filming you guys
[Music]
that'll make sense later
so i haven't done ask ij in a while and
a lot of you guys have been like justine
where are you at what are you doing well
you follow me on twitter instagram or
vine or anywhere else you know exactly
what i was doing at all times first up
don't like that question
second up how do i like the new animal
crossing for nintendo 3ds it's actually
so much fun because i used to play this
game back on the wii all the time until
i opened up my world to you guys and you
came in and destroyed everything you
took all my fruit oh here's one from
daniel who's asking how do you forget
about your ex and move on to a new
relationship
[Music]
i don't know favorite place to go on
vacation my favorite place is probably
hawaii i absolutely love hawaii it's
such a beautiful place when i go with my
family we always go to north carolina
which we actually just came back from
and depending upon when i post this i
may have already posted it but i have a
music video from harris teeter it's a
grocery store for those of you guys that
are new here what are my thoughts on
amanda bynes all right first of all i
love her i'm obsessed i read her twitter
i sit at my computer i'm refreshing like
amanda please please please tweet i need
something so i really think number one
she either needs some
help she probably does but i think it's
all an act i think it's all fake i think
she's perfectly fine i think she's
perfectly normal and she is just
trolling all of us this is the biggest
troll of 2013
maybe even 2014.
next question will you be my friend
yes will you swap face with any
celebrities if yes who will it be
i don't know
yara is asking me if i've ever thought
of using my call of duty battle skills
on a paintball field and as a matter of
fact i've actually already done that
paintball for us got my gun brian and
jenner on the other team so far team has
won every single time because we're
fabulous what is my favorite clothing
store if you're new here you may have
never seen this before this is from so
so happy and it makes me so so happy
definitely by far
my favorite daniel wants to know what
i'm getting my dad for father's day we
are actually getting him a suppressor
for his gun uh so i hope that he likes
it and i hope that this is posted after
he gets it because this really ruins the
surprise how come i never add my
subscribers on xbox well you guys may
know that you are limited to 100 people
that you can actually add but on the new
xbox one it'll be unlimited
[Music]
next question
looks like i have no more questions so
thank you guys so much for all of your
questions don't forget to subscribe and
don't forget to check out my last video
i don't know which it was so it's a
surprise
i am
sweating
okay